in 2019 i took a 9 a.m flight from
atlanta to new york city
i was the first person to board that day
so as i death gripped my phone to step
over that little crack that leads to the
runway i caught a glimpse of the flight
attendant head in her hand like this
eyes closed
the moment she heard me she looked up
she put a smile on her face and she said
good morning
this is not your first flight of the day
is it i asked no she said
it had been a really early one i made
some silly sleep joke and she laughed
and i went to go sit in my seat she
couldn't have been more than 25 years
old
during the flight we exchanged
pleasantries and at one point she came
to offer me a snack and she asked me
what i was going to new york to do
i said that i was going to deliver a
speech and that honestly i was cutting
it kind of close
no time for lunch she asked no time for
lunch i said i took a bag of almonds and
i tucked it into the pocket of my
backpack
after the flight landed i was on my way
out of the plane and she stopped me for
a moment and she handed me a plastic bag
it was about this big and it was weirdly
heavy
she said i know you didn't have a lot of
time today so i packed you this
good luck
that was nice
so as i'm walking through laguardia with
my bag and my bag
i peer inside and there are about 30
packets of almonds
inside that bag it was a bag of bags
and when i was in the taxi on the way to
the speech i found this little note
tucked inside
ms grice
thank you for coming on and putting a
smile on our faces with your sweet words
you have been so kind and we are very
lucky to have you as a loyal delta
customer thank you
i know you are gluten-free so here are
some almonds for the road
thank you for your kindness it goes a
long way
sarah delta flight attendant
now reading this my heart gave a little
jolt
my day job
is to help companies excavate and
execute their purpose
and this little note on this little
napkin was purpose in action
specifically that airlines purpose and i
know
because i had helped to articulate it
over 15 years before
in 2003 purpose was just one element of
a much larger strategic transformation
that delta airlines undertook
it was a company still reeling from the
after effects of 911
and one looking for a north star to
guide them through would eventually
become chapter 11 bankruptcy but in 2019
for a flight attendant who was maybe in
elementary school the time that purpose
was articulated
it was some almonds for a hungry
customer
it may be that sarah never saw that
purpose line we articulated but no
matter
she didn't need to
because purpose was alive and well at
delta it had become muscle memory it had
become cultural norm
now let me be clear in what i'm talking
about here i'm talking about embedding
purpose i'm not talking about your
mission which is what you do every day
or your vision which is where you are
headed both mission and vision are
important corporate drivers but they
play a different role and purpose
and mission and vision will change with
changes in leadership corporate context
competitive landscape merger and
acquisition
they are important but they are also
temporal in my experience they often
have a time horizon of say three to five
years
but purpose is your why
it is found at the intersection of who
you are at your very best
and the role in the world that you are
meant to play it comes from your ethos
it is married to your aspiration
and because it is athatic
it is also timeless
now there are plenty of data out there
to say that well-embedded purpose across
organizations brings immense value
studies that will link well-embedded
purpose to elevated total shareholder
return over 10 years increased employee
engagement retention even higher levels
of productivity
because of all this data it is rare in
my work that a ceo will come to me and
say ashley what is purpose or why do i
need to do it
instead what they will ask is when i
have my purpose
how do i embed it across my organization
so well that it brings the most value
that it becomes muscle memory
as i've been doing this work for almost
20 years at this point i have a ready
answer
first i tell them it needs to be
authentic
purpose that is rooted in your ethos
distinctive to your brand
meaningful to all of your stakeholders
and consistent with your values
is authentic
kelly bayer rose marin the ceo of optus
a sydney australia-based
telecommunications company can speak to
her company's purpose powering optimism
with options with conviction because it
is authentic
optus is by its very nature a challenger
brand and it is a brand synonymous with
a brand platform of positivity since
options breed action and optimism breeds
hope how they pull their internal
relations together with their external
reach out to customers is very
consistent and incredibly authentic
now on the other end of the authenticity
scale
i once worked with a ceo who really
wanted purpose to be about environmental
sustainability that is great i said
except for your company struggles to
even recycle in your offices i know
i've been there
while they admire the aspiration if we
had come up with a purpose line that was
solely about environmental
sustainability it would have been dead
on arrival specifically with employees
secondly i tell ceos that they must be
critical and excavating purpose from the
inside out
purpose is uncomfortable
it should be
because you are introducing a tension
between idealism and realism who you
really want to be
and who you are capable of being today
and in the future based on competencies
and ethos
and purpose can be particularly
discomforting because even once you have
it it takes a while to implement it in
fact you may set your purpose once and
spend your entire career living up to it
now purpose is particularly
uncomfortable for companies who are on a
forced evolution of change companies in
industries like oil and gas for example
or for companies who maybe have bad
behaviors they need to leave behind
finally i tell ceos that purpose must
apply to the whole of the organization
purpose is not a ceo vanity project
sure
it may help cement the legacy of the ceo
who is in charge at the time it's
articulated but it's not about them it's
not about him or her it's about the
value the company brings it is about the
role in the world that is meant to play
now purpose at the c-suite level should
be a unifying construct that brings
together mission and vision and
influences your strategic agenda
it should help ceos think about how they
redefine metrics for success
what types of topics they may want to
speak with analysts about or maybe most
importantly how the board ought to hold
them accountable as managers
purpose at the middle management level
is about much needed clarity and
authority
the middle management layer of any
organization is often the most difficult
to motivate because they have so many
different stakeholders to please
but by bringing clarity with
purpose-driven expectations and guard
rails it allows middle managers to
understand which battles to pick
and that the micro decisions they make
on a daily basis affect the company a
whole
finally
frontline employee purpose helps
employees at that level ensure that they
are seen
when purpose
is excavated and executed top floor to
shop floor those on the shop floor
understand that their work matters and
how it adds up to the overall value for
the company
well-embedded front line purpose is the
tenet behind that legendary story of
john f kennedy jr and the nasa janitor
back in 1962. you know the one where jfk
supposedly asked the janitor what do you
do for nasa and the janitor said well
i'm putting a man on the moon
in this story the janitor understood
that his role was to prepare the
building for the engineers who were
going to come in and crank on the math
but he also understood the importance of
that role to the overall vision and
objectives of nasa
that janitor understood his role in the
universe
so to speak
so many iconic
business stories begin in the back of a
cocktail napkin
but it wasn't just this napkin or even
the nuts that caused me pause that day
it was the sentiment behind it it was
the idea
if you execute
purpose across culture and strategy and
brand consistently for years
it does become muscle memory
it becomes a cultural norm
and it is that norm
that encourages an employee to make a
gift
which becomes a story
which then a very loyal customer tells
to the world
so since i am here
sarah
thank you for your kind words that day
and for the almonds
you helped make it a great day
because you were right
i was hungry
thank you
[Applause]